foreign
[Music]
hi everybody my name is Miles Ward I'm
CTO at Sada Sada is a leading Google
Cloud resale and implementation partner
we are their largest we just won partner
of the year for the sixth year in a row
I am super super excited to present to
you together with my customer and my
partner and my friend sentio their
incredible migration to Google cloud and
the adoption of its broad Suite of
Technologies uh maybe if you can give me
a quick introduction to our audience and
and break down digital term
my name is sentel I'm the CTO at digital
turbine digital turbine is a company
that's in the mobile advertising mobile
monetization
ecosystem and we Empower and enable app
Publishers and advertisers and brand
advertisers on our platform so if I if I
were to like take a step back and
playing what digital turbine is about
right
we have built a network of partners that
have adopted our technology on mobile
phones and when I say Network or
Partners these are mostly mobile
carriers and oems mobile oems that have
adopted our technology on their devices
and we have over 800 million phones
mobile phones that have our technology
on those forms right and so when you
have that sort of a reach right you
actually enable monetization at scale
right and not only are we on devices on
mobile phones but we are also in apps
I'm talking about like scale where you
know we have a 5 billion app installs
through our platforms so far right I
mean this is like you know massive scale
and
um when if you look at it through the
lens of an app publisher right if you
have a digital product right the biggest
problem that you have is how do you get
your digital products on a mobile device
and because of the network of partners
that have adopted our technology we
actually enable these digital products
to find their way onto you know mobile
devices and then in addition to that you
know with app advertisers and brand
advertisers we essentially create a
compelling story now
um
if you are a mobile app publisher right
um one of your biggest
costs is marketing sure how do you find
you know users the user acquisition is a
very you know big host for a mobile
publisher and then um you know because
of of how we have built that
network of devices that we have it
actually allows you to find your way
onto the device but then if you look at
Brand advertisers you know it's not
about distribution of apps right but
it's about brand lift brand awareness
right and being able to tell a
compelling story and the in-app presence
that we have allows the in-app and own
device presence that we have allow us to
enable brand advertisers to tell their
stories in a creative way through our
platform
so you're this connective tissue between
our application developers Global Brands
and all of the telcos that are required
to bring their products to Market if
that's the scale of what you're building
what's the scale of what you have to
deliver in order to make that real right
the systems for that have to be
incredible absolutely right uh the
numbers that you see up there are just
you know some examples of actual actual
numbers from you know one of our
platforms right this is not all of the
platforms that we have
um you know just looking at things like
10 terabytes of data a day that we
generate one billion uh ad Impressions
that we serve on a daily basis and then
one trillion outgoing transactions per
day right that's the type of scale we
are talking about on our systems
um at any point in time you know just
one single platform of ours runs thirty
thousand to fifty thousand cores right
at any point in time so that's the type
of scale that we are talking about right
and we need this type of scale when we
are talking about you know at scale ad
platform right the ad exchange the
demand side platforms that we have and
that combined with you know know
hundreds of millions of devices and you
know apps
the in-app presence that we have
requires us to you know build scale and
support a certain level of complexity
and sophistication of our platform and
we need them these are the kinds of
traffic numbers I remember from being a
googler yeah so seeing it in a
third-party system it's it's it's pretty
daunting that's it's really an
incredible achievement
I you know what was the opportunity in
front of digital turbine that that
suggested Google was the way to go
um being uh
a company that participates in the
Android ecosystem right uh we felt it
was strategy it was like really
important for us to be close to Google
right um from a strategy perspective
right
um and so that was I would say one of
them one of the motivations right which
is hey let's get close to the company
that you know plays a major role in how
this is ecosystem develops and have the
ability to kind of participate in how
you know uh the ecosystem and the
technology that powers it you know
evolves in addition to that right the
other opportunity for us was really
looking to see if there are base of you
know getting better operational
efficiency from our systems but also
from a course perspective right for this
type of scale right
um coast and Coast optimization and you
know anything that we can actually do to
get that you know scale
scaled with the better Coast construct
definitely made sense for us so it's
it's one thing to have to handle a
monster it's another thing to have to do
it at a price performance that keeps you
ahead let's let's maybe dive deeper into
some of the specific opportunities you
moved from AWS to gcp you know what were
some of the factors or or key features
that you considered
yeah
um
I would say
moving from AWS to gcp it was not for us
it was not just about a lift and shift
right I think many companies go look at
it through the lens of hey let's you
know lift and shift and honestly that's
the way we started sure when we started
we're like hey let's lift and shift but
that very quickly developed into lift
modernize and shift right so it became
more of hey what are the things that we
want to do at a platform level that
gives us the ability to you know operate
at scale with maybe more Automation and
to also reduce the burden on our teams
right and when I say burden on the teams
you know we we were a pretty devops
heavy organization and we will continue
to be a pretty devops organization the
question is can we
um you know structure our workloads in
such a way that the devops heavy
portions are where we actually need our
team's brain power right I mean we have
some real really smart Engineers who do
this and you know we should give them
the ability to kind of apply that you
know with regards to building products
and so one area for example is you know
Enterprise automation right like how do
we when we go through this journey of
you know lift modernize and shift what
are the things that we want to do at an
infrastructure level that enables us to
bring in the ability to run faster
introduce velocity the ability to you
know have more than you know n number of
releases you know per cycle right all of
those are like key motivators but you
know some of the things that that we run
into right when you look at AWS and
going to gcp is also about
what does a tech stack look like sure it
looks very different right and so there
is this whole you know Discovery and
learning you know that obviously goes
with that well there's what's great is
you've been able to help us visualize
some of the before and after you know
the transformation that happened to your
systems maybe uh you know what were some
of the technical opportunities yeah
yeah I you know um this this particular
diagram that that you're seeing actually
talks about the Enterprise automation
that we enabled on our platforms right
um and it's not only about Enterprise
automation it's also about you know
operational scale sure and automation
that's applied at operational scale um
if you see the before you can actually
see that you know we were pretty like
you know container I mean we were
containerized already we had our you
know applications on you know Docker
image and whatnot right but uh managing
those at scale is not that you know easy
when you're trying to you know scale to
the workloads that we were talking about
right so moving to you know kubernetes
right and making sure we have the right
level of orchestration to to be able to
enable that all of those are you know
super important to us and that's like
one example of you know place where we
applied it and this is you know one
example of it the other places are I
think that we have one more slide where
we actually talk about the Enterprise
automation right so the Enterprise
automation here what you're going to see
the before picture is this is devops
heavy right so whenever we try to um uh
have releases right um we we were
constrained by a number of factors
environments do we have environments
that could be leveraged for
um you know having higher higher
frequency of releases right what's it
what sort of velocity can we move with
then data is always an issue right when
you have environments like QA
environments Dev environments do you
have the ability to kind of you know run
load tests do you have the ability to
run you know things in parallel so you
can have multiple releases that are
getting ready or you can work on a patch
while you're working on a release right
so the before picture I mean it worked
for us I mean I'm not saying it did work
but the issue was it reduced our ability
to run fast with more releases and it
took a lot from the team in terms of the
lift that is required from the teams to
make things happen right well you can
see it right in there right how many
arrows go to that poor Lonesome devops
right engineer on the left that's a lot
of it looks like
toil to me yeah our devops teams are
superheroes that's right so look now
that devops engineer has maybe got some
automation on their team that's right
right so this is what our you know like
one of our products looks like after we
implemented the Enterprise Automation
and the patterns there a simple case of
you know having environments that we can
stand up and tear down and those
environments are hydrated with the data
and that the fact that you actually
hydrate these environments with data
actually enables us to do a whole lot of
things and have that flexibility and the
speed and velocity that which we can
actually ship products right and it
there's nothing worse than just
deploying the compute part and realizing
that you just haven't actually tested
anything that's right
so you've expanded your footprint it's
uh digital turbines built by acquisition
you have multiple companies and
initiatives uh talk to me about single
tap and bringing that into Google Cloud
Marketplace maybe share with the
audience how you're using Google's
Marketplace and house Auto is able to
help yeah absolutely single tab is an
enabler and it's part of our products
product Suite you know as I mentioned
you know we have a netbook of Partners
and these network of Partners tend to be
mobile carriers and you know mobile oems
that have adopted you know our core
technology on on these mobile phones
right and so
um what that enables us to do is build
new types of capabilities and single tab
is an example of that capability right
so first of all I'm going to just walk
the audience through you know what
single tab is Right single tab think of
think of you uh you know seeing an
advertisement while you're on your
mobile phone and the the ad is for for
you know for you to play you know
fortnite right when you click that ad
right essentially with that one click
you will have your you know app actually
installed on the mobile phone without
you having to go through the friction of
going into you know a Store to download
the app right so the whole idea is
single tab enables these types of
experiences where you go from you know
click to conversion right where your app
gets installed and once your app gets
installed now that becomes a point for
you to monetize and do a whole bunch of
things right so single tab is an enabler
for us and for us it is important to
connect our technology capability with
more and more you know app developers
and Publishers out there and for and you
know when we were talking about single
Tab and the growth of single tab one of
the things that you know Google and Sara
helped us with was hey you know if we
take this technology and put it on
Google marketplace is you have this you
know mechanism like an additional
channel to grow your you know develop a
footprint and the adoption of the
technology and so that's an example of
us you know taking one of our
Technologies and creating an additional
channel for expanding uh adoption and
use of you know a capability that we
enable right we're watching across so
many of our customers just explosive
growth of enabling isv tooling through
Google's Marketplace so we were just
really excited to see you added to that
rapidly growing list talk to us about
this before and after another comparison
of a modernization in your systems yeah
I mean uh you know this is yet one more
of our product platforms and you know we
actually have the uh the the the the the
brains behind this platform even sitting
here so which is great but but you know
just as an fi right I mean so this is a
before picture right uh so when we were
on AWS there were a few things where we
had some homegrown tooling to do various
things right and we were not on uh what
do I call an infrastructure that enables
us to scale and have that you know
operational scale that we wanted sure
um an example here like if you if you
see this here you are actually seeing
the before picture like we had some you
know homegrown tool that we were using
for you know continuous deployment right
and an example of lift modernize and
shift is if you go into the after
picture what you will see is we
streamline that whole process right we
moved to Argo CD and so we have this
whole process of CI CD that takes us all
the way to you know deployment on gcp
and not only that you know we are
already seeing the benefits of it which
is our ability to deploy our solution
you know much faster the velocity is
much higher and we are able to do it you
know with not burdening our you know
devops team constantly right so we built
this automation that enables us to you
know just move more you know fast and
efficiently as an organization right
that's I mean every every engineer is
doing the work to try and
help save the company money help build
the tools that are required but the that
build versus by decision and finding
places where you can springboard off of
the Investments That Google and the isv
ecosystem makes and it's just a way to
let them take seriously and as their
reason to exist that natural problem you
also changed out some of the data
systems that were a part of that I'm
interested in you talking through maybe
the move from dynamodb yeah we did
actually we moved from Dynamo DB to
bigtable right we are talking about
massive scale here in terms of you know
our data moving from dynamodb to uh you
know a big table but in addition to that
we moved from VMS to gke right uh we are
talking about like 8 000 you know nodes
on the gke right and so this is again
you know massive scale in terms of you
know what we do and then of course
moving away from the Homegrown you know
tool and moving to standardized open
tools enables us to kind of focus on
what we really want to be doing which is
Building Products right right well we we
brought a little surprise I wanted to
put this in front of folks can anybody
squint and see what their is that
totally legible there in the back oh no
probably not so I want to be clear you
know we've talked about just really the
tip of the iceberg of the nuance and
complexity that went into this migration
this is the actual project planning of
some 2600 distinct steps between dozens
and dozens of team members on your side
and dozens on side aside not only to
arrive on overall governance of the
program but to coordinate the education
and collaboration around refining to
final design and then working through
the logistics of deployment and then sun
setting of subsequent systems so it's
this stuff is not it's not obvious right
everybody's used to one of those simple
architecture diagrams you're going to do
two phases and then you're done the
reality is it does take the complicated
coordinated work to run the real problem
to ground uh you know I'm just super
interested what you know what part of
this obviously easy to read plan stood
out for you is uh you know a place where
we really work together well
um
it's moving from one cloud provider to
another is is a journey right and you
know as an organization like any others
who may also be considering that you
know you should really
um have a strong partner going into that
Journey because you know otherwise
you're going to be lost along the way
right and you know as we went through
this journey there are uh you know
there's always new discoveries and new
learnings and then we find way to
quickly iterate and adapt and say okay
this is how we are going to solve
problems but specifically if I look at
you know our plan
um it you know there are places where I
would say the world right there are new
learnings along the way for example you
know uh when we calculated our you know
uh the move from one platform to the
other you know we run into various types
of uh what do I call uh challenges with
regards to what our assumptions were and
what it actually turned out pretty it
turned out to be we had for example Sada
along the way as we actually did this
but on the project planning side of
things right
this has to be run these complex
projects have to be run as a Clockwork
right with responsible parties and
making sure that we have also the
resourcing to move fast on areas where
we get blocked right I would say the key
areas that stood out for me were like
how the teams worked together to handle
um you know blockers right any time when
something gets delayed it has a
financial implication for us just keep
in mind you know as you're going through
this journey for us the way we
orchestrated it is you know we had this
double bubble right which means we are
running our services on AWS while we're
bringing our power services on gcp and
we were shifting traffic right and why
it was important for us to do that is we
want zero downtime and zero impact to
revenue right so if you if you don't
want any impact Revenue when you're
trying to drive that complex project you
actually have to have all you know eyes
on glass in terms of how that's running
and managing that you know at scale when
you're talking about the type of scale I
talked about is complex and you know
that from a point of view of planning
and mapping out all those different
pieces the cut-overs right how the
traffic ramps up what sort of costs are
we incurring because you know you want
to like scale but you want you don't
want to you know scale so much that you
over provision your infrastructure so
all of that right are parts and parcel
of the plan and you really want to kind
of hold to those plans
so look I hope everybody's internalized
how much progress this represents how
did Sada and Google together
advise you on this plan with regard to
all the choices that you had to make
um there are multiple Dimensions to the
to the uh you know I would say that
partnership right from an advising
perspective right one is
um all the math that goes into the cloud
deployment costs and calculations and
all that right and you know one of the
resources that we had from Sada was you
know this financial Guru right and you
know he knew more than you know what we
knew about the coast and the coast of
scaling and the cost of uh you know
moving from one platform to the other
and it's a fine art right you have to
juggle your Coast across multiple Cloud
providers while you're trying to do it
and you know that's one area where we
heavily leaned on uh on both Sara and
and Google for doing that
um then in addition to that right there
is all
um all the refactoring that you're doing
right and you know we are doing some
heavy refactoring as we were trying to
you know modernize our application and
then technology is right I mean if you
look at AWS not everything that you have
on AWS that we had was you know how do I
call it Cloud agnostic right right we
had a number of things that were Cloud
native and you know we also wanted to
lean on a partner to help us with
driving specific technology decisions
that enabled us to kind of really try
and future proof what we're trying to do
now keep in mind you know this morning's
uh you know not the keynote I thought
was very interesting which is about you
know Legacy and you know I mean yes we
have a solid Legacy platform but when we
try to modernize it you know how it is
today's modern is tomorrow's you know
Legacy right so that's right so we tried
to Future proof as much as possible and
um making the right technology decisions
as we're thinking about it thinking
about the scale and how we are going to
go there those are the decisions that we
heavily leaned on on Sara as well Google
awesome
so okay you did an incredible amount of
work right I saw a gazillion steps what
what was the outcome how did this how
did this positively affect the business
um I would say a number of ways right
because one is you know I talked about
you know ship velocity right shivalocity
refers to our ability to quickly iterate
deploy and you know run things through
automation right some of these we
haven't fully realized the benefits of
it right but you know we have early
indicators that we that we are going to
actually reduce some of the operational
burdens right and get to you know where
we want to be
um from a business outcome perspective
there are things that you know the
closer partnership that we have with
Google Drives right through Marketplace
you know what we are seeing with you
know single Tab and what we are trying
to do there but from a technology
outcome you know perspective right I
would say you know we have used this as
an opportunity to modernize our
application and that means you know the
whole uh scaling aspect of it is
something that we have figured out and
then in addition to that right one of
the key components for us from a growth
perspective is how we think about
data right and how we leverage the data
that we generate from our systems we are
in the process of going through this
evaluation where we can leverage our new
platform capabilities to do more with
data right and do more with AI right we
haven't gone deep there yet right but
that's you know going to be a set of
outcomes that we are excited about I I
just can't wait uh I am telling you what
I am watching happen uh in in businesses
every day around those Technologies is
so mind-blowing given your faculty with
change and your team's ability to work
hard on pursuit of innovation I think
you're set up to do totally incredible
stuff so uh maybe learnings takeaways
for our audience how what should they uh
incorporate as they anticipate their own
migration yeah I would say uh you know
first step really understand the
the whole impact that you're going to
have as you're going through this
process right
um what I mean by impact is you know it
is it is uh it is going to be a very
involved exercise as you are going to
move from one Cloud prior to the other
and it will have some impact on your
roadmap and your ability to deliver you
know specific features and building
specific products so having a strong
partner in the process right that will
help augment and help accelerate is is a
very key component of this right so
that's for from for for us you know how
do you like really tune the knob with
regards to how much you want the partner
to do versus how much you want you know
our Engineers to do it's always a fine
balance right because keep in mind when
we're in production you want your
engineers to be able to you know take it
and run it right and so you have to
maintain that balance the second is you
know just learnings around technology
choices right having knowledgeable
parties that can actually guide you and
help you through the you know technology
decisions that you're making as you're
on this journey is important because
it's going to set you up for Success you
know in the future right
um and then you know overall
um this takes
certain amount of you know how do I call
it
program management across the board
right with your partners but also with
internally within the organization and
culturally you have to create that
awareness culturally you have to like
you know our your teams have to feel
that they are empowered right on this
journey right because at the tail end of
the journey your teams are going to be
moving from one cloud provider to
another so you have to help your teams
get up leveled that education that
awareness you know being ready to kind
of operate at scale are all important
right as you're thinking through this
channel
well look I I really appreciate the the
praise and the positive feedback it is
it is impossible to drive these kinds of
outcomes with customers that are not
ready to change that aren't are not
invested in the potential that Google
and the broader technologies that we're
working on present I thought your teams
did an absolutely outstanding job of
wrapping their arms around found that
vision of what was possible and seeing
the results from that work has been very
gratifying it's an important part of why
we do what we do so thank you for the
partnership yeah no absolutely and and
there are certain things that you know
as we were building the platform we
tried to build those constructs the
fundamentals right you know one simple
example is security right rather than
you know the reactive nature that we
were going through what when we
modernize can we do at the core of the
platform so that is standardized across
the board right that's one example of it
right but you know those are things that
helps immensely yeah no I mean I think
having having the business coordinated
around especially a business built by
acquisition with so many different
divisions getting to program and pattern
consistency really pays dividends for
you more than many others I suspect well
look I I want to thank you for our
audience uh and thank you in the
audience for uh or listening through
Cynthia's incredible story The Journey
continues that flow chart doesn't stop
at the end we've got we've got a lot
more left to do I'm just really excited
for what we're going to be able to
accomplish together likewise you know
very excited about this journey with
Sada and Google
foreign